jean-luc mabec bonjour ça va bien oui
habitude il faut que ça aille bien parce
que très honnêtement la bonne humeur
régis dans notre quotidien le plaisir de
vivre absolument c'est une sorte
d'élégance à la bonne humeur tu es bien
fait bien alors justement bonne humeur
alors voyager vous êtes plus que de la
bonne humeur c'est la vie c'est de la
vienne dans les entrailles dans tout ça
vous ai parlé de rabelais et ne garder
un gargantua alors gardons tu là ça
vient de quoi eh bien ça vient du fait
que le papa de gargantua dès qu'ils
n'aient pratiquement
s'aperçoit que ce bébé moss comme un
ogre et il lui dit
grand gorge tu as et sa garde gang à la
grotte voilà à blaye était un ennemi
affiché du politiquement correct il faut
savoir que le gargantua à sa sortie fut
interdite puis petit à petit il se
trouve que la société s'est détendu et à
la lecture du premier ouvrage de
rappelèrent considéré que second était
lisible aussi mais à l'époque un jeu de
bruit bien sûr alors génie de la
littérature et puis surtout vision
incroyablement d'avenir moderne on
pourrait aujourd'hui considérer que
rabelais aurait sa place dans le cercle
des écrivains d'aujourd'hui ce grand
bonhomme tête et gargantua n'a pas pris
une ride et il faut savoir que
aujourd'hui on le compare souvent à un
ogre un grand nez mais en réalité dans
l'oeuvre de rabelais gargantua est
d'abord un apprenti guerrier gargantua
va être connu dans son nouveau dans
l'ouvragé de rabelais par ces grandes
aventures guerrières alors bien entendu
autour de ses aventures derrière il y à
la bonne chère ball chair il ya le
plaisir il ya un peu tout il ya un peu
de 5 ceux ci un oui je ne vais pas dire
quand même mais c'est vrai de vous
parler des dégâts mais les guerres
picrocholines notamment un kit et où on
se bat pour rien absents écoutez si vous
regardez un peu la vie politique
aujourd'hui il y en a déguerpi compagnie
hélas hélas mais on est aussi à l'époque
parce qu'il faut se replacer dans le
contexte du moment en pleine guerre de
religion et rabelais et protestants
rabelais lutte contre la secte isme pour
au contraire la bonne chère et le bien
vivre le bien vivre par le bien manger
par la jouissance est donc imaginer à
cette époque dans ces guerres de
religion les protestants défendent des
valeurs plutôt un
protestant c'est extraordinaire et puis
y'a même je pense quelques recettes
qu'on pourrait qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui absolument d'ailleurs elles
sont
sur internet on peut détruire assez
facilement ce sont des réseaux est un
petit peu à l'ancienne mais dans le
texte dans la formulation des phrases de
rabelais quelle modernité quelle
modernité bla merci beaucoup et j'ai
envie que le mec et puis on pourrait
dire vive l'humanisme vite d'humanisme
patrice à bientôt et à bientôt